C'est quoi ça ?
Attend mais c'est une météorite ?
Tu fais quoi avec un œuf de Yoni toi ?
Un quoi ?
Vous savez que c’est une obligation légale d’aller à la police quand on a un cadavre sur les bras ?
T’inquiète pas Valentine. On va essayer de bien s’en occuper pour passer à autre chose.
Normalement c’est des chrysanthèmes à un enterrement,
mais c’est pas grave, c’est l’intention qui compte.
Pourquoi il pleut toujours les lendemains d’enterrement ?
Peut-être pour laver nos âmes de la déprime et enfin nous permettre de passer à autre chose.
Et si on ne veut pas passer à autre chose ?
Genre, laisser une trace ?
On peut se faire embaumer, comme Lénine ?
La plus vieille momie a 9400 ans. C’est pas éternel.
Moi, perso,  je suis chaud pour être cryogénisé.
Bof, ça c’est approuvé ni par la communauté scientifique, ni par le corps médical.
Piégé dans l’ambre.
Comme dans Jurassic Park.
Ça, ça marche sur les insectes et les petits machins, mais un truc gros et plein d’eau comme nous...
Écrire un livre ?
Un chef d’œuvre, comme le code civil…
Mouais, à mon avis, la postérité ultime, ce serait de devenir un fossile.
En fait, tu as décidé de poser une question à laquelle personne n’a de réponse,
juste pour plomber l’ambiance.
Déjà, on a de la chance d’avoir un squelette, ça sera beaucoup plus facile.
Les os traversent beaucoup mieux les âges que les parties molles.
Les chairs disparaissent, au mieux on en garde une empreinte mais c’est ultra rare.
Mais même malgré ça, il faut vraiment des conditions environnementales très particulières pour arriver à fossiliser.
Le mieux, c’est le fond d’un lac ou d’une mer peu profonde.
Comme ça, les sédiments vont nous recouvrir rapidement et ça évite 1. qu’on se fasse boulotter par les charognards,
et 2. qu'il y ait trop d’oxygène à notre contact.
Comme ça, ça va ralentir notre décomposition
et ça nous donne plus de temps pour fossiliser en paix, comme disait Stéphane Escher.
Sinon, dans une tourbière ça marche aussi vu que c’est aussi un milieu pauvre en oxygène.
A partir de là, on a deux options.
Dans le premier pack “voyage inoubliable”, nos chairs se décomposent alors que l’eau imbibe notre squelette.
Peu à peu, les minéraux transportés par cette eau vont cristalliser dans les pores de nos os.
Ils vont nous solidifier tout le tralala, et même le ding ding dong.
C’est la perminéralisation.
Dans le deuxième pack, notre ultime berceau de sédiments s’indure suffisamment pour faire un moulage de notre corps.
Corps qui est dégradé et qui donc disparaît, alors que d’autres minéraux remplissent les trous.
Du coup ça sera plus vraiment nous, mais un moulage à l’identique,
vous savez, comme ces lapins de Pâques en chocolat.
Tout le monde ne le sait pas, mais ils ont été moulés sur des vrais cadavres de bébés lapins.
Ils ajoutent la clochette après.
Et après justement ?
Si le but est juste de laisser une trace comme on fait pipi sur un mur, pour exister, pour pas tomber dans l’oubli, ou parce qu’on a la vessie pleine,
ça n’a qu’un intérêt assez limité à mes yeux.
On pourrait en profiter pour transmettre des connaissances, tant qu’à faire.
On pourrait être l’émissaire de notre civilisation actuelle.
A condition qu’une personne du futur tombe sur nous en binant ses carottes 5.0.
Par contre, faut même pas imaginer emporter une valise là où on va.
Du coup, à moins de se graver la Critique de la raison pure sur le tibia,
le paléontologue du turfu aura du mal à reconstituer notre culture.
Là, le paléontologue du turfu pourra essayer de dresser notre portrait robot.
En prélevant notre ADN s’il nous en reste un peu, il pourra essayer de nous relier à d’éventuels autres fossiles et nous replacer dans le grand arbre du vivant.
Du vivant et du mort, du coup.
En étudiant la morphologie de notre squelette, il pourrait essayer d’en déduire si on porte des œufs ou si on est vivipare,
si on est bipède, tripède ou quadrupède.
S’il nous ausculte comme un médecin légiste de l’extrême, il pourra essayer d’en déduire de quoi on est mort.
Et quand, aussi, en datant la roche autour de nous.
Finalement, ce qui perdurera de nous, ce n’est pas ce qu’on possède,
ce qu’on sait, ce qu’on a appris, mais uniquement ce qu’on est.
Un humain bipède vivipare omnivore, un peu scoliosé parce qu’on a fait trop d’ordi.
Personne ne se souviendra qu’on a lu La Fontaine, Descartes et Super Picsou Géant,
qu’on a vu le sosie officiel de Florent Pagny en concert,
ni même que toutes ces choses ont existé un jour finalement.
Personne ne saura que ce qu’on préfère par-dessus tout, c’est l’odeur des pâtes qui cuisent et le goût du malaise.
C’est vrai que si on regarde dans le passé, dans le domaine qui me correspond un peu, donc dans la linguistique et la linguistique historique notamment.
Du coup, je ne vais pas trop parler d’archéologie ou
d’interpréter ce qu’il y a dans les tombes etc., Clothilde en avait déjà parlé dans la première saison.
Mais linguistiquement parlant, effectivement, ce qu’on a, c’est des textes.
Et les textes, c’est vachement important pour deux choses.
Déjà, parce que ça donne une information sur la langue.
Comment tu écrivais la langue, c’est quoi sa grammaire, c’est quoi les mots qui étaient utilisés, c’est quoi les formes.
Donc cela permet de reconstituer l’histoire de la langue, et aussi tout simplement le fond du texte.
C'est-à-dire, de quoi ça parle, ça donne des informations sur la société, sur les gens, sur comment ils vivaient etc.
Déjà, ce n’est pas toujours facile parce que les textes ont les a de manière parcellaire, on n’a pas tout, on n’a pas forcément beaucoup de contexte.
On peut avoir ce qu’on appelle des hapax. Un hapax, c’est un mot qui n’apparaît qu’une fois.
On a qu’une occurrence du mot dans la langue.
Du coup, on peut parfois le déduire par le contexte quand on a des traductions.
Des fois pas du tout, on ne sait juste pas du tout ce que cela veut dire et ça fait des textes à trous.
Et en fait, le truc, c’est que,
avant l’écriture, tu as un espèce d’angle mort sur ce qui pouvait se passer. Parce que tu peux très bien reconstruire des langues, ça on le fait.
C’est-à-dire on prend des langues relativement proches et on arrive à reconstruire un stade plus ou moins antérieur,
avec des méthodes que l’on appelle la méthode de la grammaire comparée.
C’est ce que j’ai étudié moi justement.
Le truc, c’est que, arrive un moment où il y a tout de même un angle mort.
Tu arrives à arriver à un stade antérieur, mais tu ne peux pas tout reconstruire.
C’est-à-dire qu’aujourd’hui, [inaudible] européen, qui est probablement la langue
reconstruite, la plus reconstruite, et celle qui nous projette le plus loin dans le passé,
c’était il y a 6 ou 8000 ans. C’était il n’y a pas si longtemps que ça quoi.
Et pareil, il y a aussi une question, c’est :
“est-ce que c’est ce que tu veux léguer qu’on retrouve ?”
Et à cette question, je pense qu’on peut dire non.
Parce qu’il y a bien des trucs genre les stèles funéraires etc., quoiqu’aujourd’hui, je ne sais pas si les gens de l’époque quand ils enterraient leurs morts, ils pensaient qu’on allait les déterrer
et chopper les petits morceaux de texte qu’il y avait dedans pour essayer de comprendre comment ils parlaient. Je pense que ce n’était pas le délire à l’époque.
Et il y a aussi tout simplement, ce qu’on retrouve, ça n’a pas l’air d’être ce que les gens ont voulu léguer.
Quand tu retrouves que machin se plaint qu’on ne lui a pas livré la bonne quantité de céréales ou ce genre de trucs.
Et il y a tout simplement que parfois les gens ont beaucoup écrit, mais on ne sait pas ce qu’ils ont écrit. On ne comprend pas ce qu’ils ont écrit.
Par exemple, sur l’île de Crète, où il y avait la civilisation minoenne au 2e millénaire avant notre ère,
on a trouvé des textes qui sont appelés en linéaire-A,
parce qu’on en avait deux, on avait linéaire-A et linéaire-B.
Linéaire-B, on l’a déchiffré dans les années 50, mais linéaire-A, on ne l’a toujours pas déchiffré, on ne sait toujours pas ce que ça veut dire.
On ne sait même pas dans quelle langue c’est écrit.
On a des idées, mais il n’y a pas de consensus établi, il n’y a pas de traduction qui a été faite.
Il y a même des fois, on ne sait pas si c’est une langue ou pas.
Par exemple, le disque de Phaistos qui a été retrouvé aussi sur l'île de Crète, à côté du Linéaire-A,
c’est des disques avec des symboles,
on ne sait pas si c’est du texte ou si c’est juste un con qui a dessiné des dessins.
On ne peut pas savoir, on ne sait pas. C’est ça aussi.
Et pour finir, il y a des moments où c’est vraiment des trucs très cons qui pour nous sont vraiment fondamentaux en linguistique,
qu’on a retrouvés, mais qui sont vraiment des trucs très anecdotiques.
Du genre, l’appendix probi, c’est une liste de mots en bas-latin, donc en latin après le 1e siècle.
Une liste de mots que les gens prononçaient mal, c’est-à-dire, il y a un gars qui a fait une liste de mots :
“il ne faut pas dire comme ça, faut dire comme ça”. Alors pour nous, c’est très intéressant linguistiquement parlant, ça nous permet de
retracer l’évolution de la langue.
Mais je pense que ce n’est pas ce que les gens de cette époque voulaient léguer,
ils ne voulaient pas léguer une liste de fautes.
Enfin une liste de ce qu'étaient des fautes à l’époque, parce qu’en fait, c’est que des trucs qui sont rentrés dans la langue courante aujourd’hui.
Quand tu vois, que des fois, il y a des civilisations qui ont duré des centaines voire des milliers d’années
où y avait vraiment une vie, une écriture, y avait une langue, y avait une société etc.
et qu’on voit ce qui nous reste, quasiment rien,
ça fout un peu le seum.. parce que du coup, qu’est-ce qu’il va rester de nous.
Depuis le début du XXe siècle, des chercheurs songent très sérieusement à ressusciter des espèces éteintes comme on a rebooté Jésus à Pâques.
Et grâce à l’avènement de Crispr, ces ciseaux génétiques extraordinaires, l’opération paraît un peu plus faisable.
Je m’explique.
Jusqu’à maintenant, la technique de clonage qu’on utilisait consistait à transférer le noyau d’une cellule du donneur dans l’ovule dénoyauté d’une espèce proche génétiquement,
de prier très fort et paf ! Ca fait un clone. Parfois.
C’est comme ça qu’est née la brebis Dolly en 1996.
C’était le tout premier mammifère cloné de l’Histoire.
Et d’ailleurs, pour l’anecdote, les créateurs de la biquette l’auraient baptisée en hommage à Dolly Parton,
une chanteuse de country américaine à la poitrine généreuse,
parce qu’ils avaient utilisé des cellules de glande mammaire pour cloner la bête.
Classe, distingué, raffiné. Ça, c’est la science qu’on aime.
Mais bon, cette méthode n’est pas franchement idéale, puisque les clones sont souvent mal finis.
Dolly (la brebis) avait de l’arthrose, des problèmes respiratoires et elle a vieilli prématurément. La pauvresse.
Si c’est pour revivre dans ces conditions, c’est peut-être pas l’idéal…
Heureusement, une nouvelle technique est apparue il y a quelques années : Crispr, alias les ciseaux génétiques.
Au départ, c’est une famille de petits bouts d’ADN qui se baladent dans des bactéries et qui ont un superpouvoir.
S’ils voient passer un virus, ils le repèrent et le détruisent avant que le virus n’ait eu le temps d’infecter la bactérie-hôte.
Ces petits soldats font ça en détectant et découpant des séquences d’ADN bien précises qu’ils reconnaissent dans le génome du virus.
Voyant ça, deux biologistes, Emmanuelle Charpentier et Jennifer Doudna, se sont dit : "attendez voir.
Puisque ça sait reconnaître des portions d’ADN et que ça le découpe à un endroit bien précis,
ça pourrait pas nous permettre de copier-coller des gènes dans le génome de ce qu’on veut ?"
Et c’est ainsi qu’elles ont mis au point les ciseaux génétiques Crispr/Cas9,
qui permettent de modifier le génome de plein d’organismes : des oiseaux, des insectes, des reptiles, des mammifères…
Et oui, y compris l’humain.
Ce qui pose plein de questions d’ordre éthique, surtout depuis qu’un chercheur chinois s’est amusé en 2018 à fabriquer des bébés Crispr, mais c’est une autre histoire.
Bref. Ces ciseaux génétiques sont incroyablement précis.
Il y a encore quelques petits soucis à régler, notamment de off-target
des fois, ils peuvent engendrer des mutations non désirées dans le génome, c’est plutôt balot).
Mais ça reste un outil extrêmement prometteur.
Les chercheurs améliorent constamment cette famille d’outils, donc ça ne peut aller qu’en s’améliorant de toute façon.
L’impact est tel sur la discipline qu’on parle carrément de révolution.
Au printemps 2015, Emmanuelle Charpentier et Jennifer Doudna étaient listées par le Time Magazine parmi les 100 personnes les plus influentes du monde.
Donc, revenons-en à nos mammouths.
Une fois qu’on a séquencé le génome du mammouth
et celui de l’éléphant d’Asie (son plus proche parent actuel),
on pourrait imaginer utiliser Crispr pour pimper le génome du second et le faire ressembler au premier.
Avec nos ciseaux, on ouvrirait l’ADN de l’éléphant comme un collier de perles, on y ajouterait quelques perlouses dans le même ordre que le collier du mammouth
et on recollerait le tout ensemble.
Eh bien c’est exactement ce qu’a fait George Church, généticien à l’université d’Harvard.
En 2015, il a introduit des gènes de mammouth dans des cultures cellulaires de peau d’éléphant.
C’était la première fois que ces gènes de mammouth se retrouvaient à nouveau fonctionnels… dans une boîte de Pétri, hein. Calmez-vous.
Mais Church a de l’ambition.
Au sein de son laboratoire, le Harvard Woolly Mammoth Revival, il trifouille les cellules d’éléphants
pour obtenir un genre de cellules souches de pseudo-mammouth.
Enfin, de mammouphant.
Puis il les spécialise en divers types de cellules, par exemple globules rouges, des poils ou des cellules graisseuses, pour voir si elles ont bien les caractéristiques qu’on attend chez un mammouth.
Quand il sera satisfait, il pourra reprendre ces cellules souches et en faire un embryon de mammouphant,
qu’il compte incuber dans un utérus artificiel.
Ça, c’est la science qu’on aime.
Bon par contre, c’est pas pour demain.
Certes, le génome de l’éléphant d’Asie et celui du mammouth sont similaires à 99.96 %,
mais il reste quand-même 1,4 millions de perlouses (pardon, de nucléotides) qui les séparent.
Ça en fait des manipulations génétiques !
Ce qu’envisage Church,
en tout cas dans un premier temps, c’est plutôt de fabriquer un éléphant qui supporte le froid en empruntant quelques traits au mammouth.
Ce qui est déjà pas mal, mais on est encore loin de ressusciter le casting de l’ ge de Glace.
En suivant le même principe, on pourrait imaginer bidouiller le génome d’un poulet et obtenir un vrai T. rex.
On passe sur les séquelles psychologiques de maman poulette.
Imaginez si vous attendiez un bébé et qu’en fait surprise, vous accouchiez de votre tata Jacquie, qui est morte il y a 50 ans.
Mais là, on se heurte encore à un autre problème. C’est que pour pouvoir reproduire une peinture de maître, il nous faut le tableau de départ !
Si on n’a pas le génome du T. rex, on ne peut rien faire.
Et à l’heure actuelle, on n’a toujours pas trouvé d’ADN de T. rex suffisamment bien conservé.
C’est une molécule très fragile qui commence à se dégrader dès qu’on passe l’arme à gauche.
Du coup, pas d’ADN de T. rex, pas de clone. Pas de clone, pas de clone. Voilà.
On peut ressusciter 17 fois le chien de Barbra Streisand mais pas une seule fois un Dents Tranchantes.
Mais bon, mettons qu’on arrive à fossiliser notre corps.
Qu’il traverse les âges. Qu’il reste dessus assez d’ADN pour pouvoir nous cloner.
Qu’il soit retrouvé après par une civilisation qui arrive désormais à ressusciter des fossiles. Qu’ils en aient l’envie, aussi, accessoirement.
Bon, soit. Ils nous font un beau petit clone à notre effigie, l’Igor de notre Grichka.
Reste encore à transférer notre conscience dans cette nouvelle coquille.
Et là encore, on n’y est pas du tout du tout, vu qu’on sait même pas vraiment ce que c’est, la conscience...
Bref. Là, on est très clairement dans de la science-fiction.
Je crois qu’il va falloir se faire à l’idée qu’y a peu de chances que ni vous, ni moi, ni Monté, ni vous, on ne laisse de trace durable sur cette planète.
Bonne journée :)
Merci d’avoir regardé cette toute dernière vidéo de cette saison du Vortex.
J’espère qu’elle vous aura plu.
Et si vous aimez la mort, n’hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo, à vous abonner, à la partager, à commenter et à nous rejoindre sur le Discord
pour parler des Bogdanov et de plein d’autres choses extrêmement intéressantes.
C’était pas une météorite, c’était un œuf de Yoni. Et en plus, c’était même pas à ta cousine, Valentine. C’était à moi, je suis vraiment désolé.
On sait. Depuis un moment déjà.
De toute façon avec Florence on a pris la décision de déménager.
- J’me suis occupé des papiers. C’est mieux comme ça.
- Quoi ? Non ? Vous n’allez pas partir comme ça ? Comment on va faire...
Comment on va faire pour le loyer ?
Vous allez bien trouver une solution.
Eh merde.
Elles sont sérieuses ou...
Et pour bien conclure cette saison du Vortex, je vous propose de me rejoindre maintenant.
Tout de suite, sur Touiche.
Y aura le lien en description quelque part.
J'y serai là à la diffusion de la vidéo, comme ça on va pouvoir débriefer ensemble,
toutes les choses merveilleuses qui s'y sont dites.
Et puis voilà, si vous avez des questions sur le fait d'être insignifiant dans ce monde,
et de ne pas laisser de trace après sa mort, n'hésitez pas.
Ça va être bien. Aller ! Venez !